jason's in houston texas hey jason how
are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so i run a wholesale trading business
and so i have to
spend around forty to fifty thousand
dollars per month on
inventory and so right now i know how
you feel about this but right now i put
it on a credit card
and basically it gives me around two
thousand dollars
a month in cash back and so what i do is
i just
basically live off of the cash back and
then all of my business income
i just invest it and so i was trying to
see what the
pitfalls of this are i guess
so yeah well these kinds of plans only
work if everything goes perfect
if your sales go down four months in a
row
you're freaking bankrupt
right but i'm only buying i mean 40 000
a month is only what you're buying
right or no i'm buying based on what my
customers order from me so
it's like they order first and then i
just drop ship the item to them
yeah so then why then why are you having
to borrow money
i'm not doing it to borrow money i'm
mainly just doing it because
it's saving me two thousand dollars a
month right now that's
okay so they pay you they pay you and
you can use their money to do the drop
ship you don't need to do this
yeah good don't do it anymore
you're playing with snakes son you're
gonna get bit
okay no millionaire ever said i made all
my money with cash back
on credit cards you're screwing around
with rattlesnakes and
like it's a sport your risk meter is
broken
or here's a better way to think jason
what are they getting from you
no company just gives money away for fun
so
why are they giving you two thousand
dollars every month
what are they getting from you right
i guess that's my information that they
get
but they're also getting a long-term
play with you
they have their hooks in you dude
because you've normalized this
in your spirit and in your process
listen here's the thing here's another
example okay
i used to how old are you 20 5
19. 19. okay um
when i i was 22 years old i started
buying real estate with nothing down
and the rent i brought in was on each
property was
more than the payment
but i was in debt up to my eyeballs on
the properties and i did not perceive
that as risk because the cash was
flowing
does that make sense and here's what i
do that's called nothing down real
estate you buy real estate with nothing
down the bank finances 100 of it because
you got a deal on it
and it's the same kind of line of
thinking that you're using
and um
uh here's what i learned ten years later
i knew i knew a whole bunch of guys that
were 40 years old 50 years old 20 years
old 30 years old that were doing
nothing down real estate a decade later
let me tell you how many of them were
not how many of them were still doing
real estate
zero we were all
out of business because we were playing
with snakes
and we got bit so here's a plan
you're obviously a great you obviously
have a good
business mind your risk meter is not
functioning well you are not perceiving
the risk that you are taking
that's what i'm saying and i didn't
either it is the beauty of youth however
um you know this is you know this is the
same i'm the same idiot that used to go
over a piece of plywood on a bicycle
that was propped up by
six bricks and with no bike helmet and
then wonder why you get all your teeth
knocked out of your head you know i'm
the same guy
the beauty of youth is you do not
perceive risk
and it just looked like fun yes and it
looked like what kind of how could this
go wrong
it can't only be more awesome it could
only be better
more bricks if we get two thousand back
let's try twice as much we'll get four
thousand back well so here's what i said
stop doing this man go back to simple
old people way of thinking
and pay for your business as it goes and
then you will business your business
will survive
up and down and you will not get caught
with the last man
holding the beans and get your dead gum
head taken off by these guys
i want to lean into what you said about
this being in your spirit because
i was a executive officer i was a nerd
in college
no surprise and with the student
government and a year i was a treasurer
so i worked i ran everything through my
private credit card
and accumulated the miles and then i
just got a check reimbursement every
month
and it worked great i got these miles
over here or whatever the things were
back then
and i was it was no worse to wear
the school is always going to pay me
back it's when my transmission fell out
of my 88 turtle easy hatchback
which was a dope car by the way easy
hatchback was a dope car
it was not it was awful that was sarcasm
um so i had this check for 500 it was
supposed to go to pay this thing off oh
oh
but i'm holding this thing i literally
need a transmission
yeah and thus started well thus you know
this is what happens with a pyramid
scheme
that's right i was floating this one to
pay for this and try to get this
financial jenga
and it always comes crashing down it's
financial jenga and but i'm the one that
can beat it
thus there's the arrogance of youth and
or just the arrogance period you don't
have to be young to be arrogant but
it helps and um and my mind caught me
years later when i brought a human into
the world right and it had
piled and kicked and moved and punted
and shifted and we can roll it over here
the debt not the human that's right
that's all that too but at some point
you pay the piper and usually
it just snowballs on you in the opposite
direction well yeah
because you do get um i'll use one of
your terms a psychological term
satiated yeah you get used to
you know a way of living away if you hit
the curve at 120
instead of 35 you get used to hitting
the curve at 120.
then when you hit it at 35 you feel like
you're like like you're crawling like
who would do this because everybody
knows you can make it at 120
until you until the tire blows that's
right and and then you figure out why
the stupid thing had a sign up that said
35 not 120.
and you know when you go rolling over
the embankment or there's a little bit
of rain
and that's that there's always these
variables and so
it's the best way to get rich quick
is get rich slow
it's the proven the data proves it
that's the best way to do it because
otherwise you have to do it over and
over and over again
i know this is the ramsay show